hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign or again and
yes you see the title you also see the
video length it's gonna be a little bit
confusing but yes ice brawler's and all
that stuff and the frost one festival is
returning but we got a little bit of
things to talk about because of that so
yes for a week the frost wind festival
ice brawler's all that stuff it's
returning from January 9th to January
16th which is a week it's just like it
was back in the day
ice brawlers is back the emotes and mask
outfits are back as well as well as ice
brawler's is the returning event mode
for a bit and all the frost win'
festival weapons are back too it's
basically just like we're back in year
one again except it's just like we're
back in year one again there's no new
weapons the new heroes which are pretty
much all the new bulan and the new
harbingers we've gotten this year have
none of the customization options
because they were not out in the game
when frost when festival was a thing so
I believe to my knowledge they won't be
getting anything although it could be
wrong and honestly even though I say
that that's really not a big deal I'm
seeing this more as a way for new
players to catch up who didn't get to
play the event back in year 1 and I'm
also seeing this as old players such as
myself who may be switched platforms or
switched characters can now get gear for
those specific heroes when we didn't
really feel like playing them back in
year 1 overall I think regardless this
is something to tide us over for a
little bit until year 4 comes it won't
be too long though it is only going to
be a week of content but it's still
better than nothing in my opinion also
as I was making this video they had
actually released a blog post talking
about the January roadmap so if you were
one of the very first people that saw
the original video but didn't get to see
the next part I do apologize they
uploaded this as soon as I did so we do
have the January roadmap it is on screen
now as you can see we're already in
January 9th so the beginning stuff isn't
really a big deal we already know that
weren't campaign 5 new content of the
week which we talked about and then we
have the frost one festival it's going
to be going on for a week then the
testing grounds is going to be starting
from January 16th to January 30th
presumably with the Centurion rework I
really do hope so and then we also have
the faction war results on the 17th of
January followed by a couple challenges
with the hero trial for the bull
if you don't know what the hero trials
is basically that is a small little
weekend to week where anybody can play
any of the new characters either I
believe it's for free or at a discounted
price I still think it's free and then
once that week or weekend is over then
you cannot play the characters again but
if you do choose to decide to play them
afterwards buy them for steel or
whatever paths you happen to get them
with then you'll keep all your
progression it's and it's as if you
played them like weeks before then
double xp is coming up on the 24th we've
got some new content on the 30th
presumably executions I'm going to say
seeing as we are slowly approaching
February and for my calculations it is
going to be the end of January or early
February is when year 4 is going to come
out so I'm going to predict that this
may or may not be executions and if this
isn't executions then we're still gonna
get some juicy ass content with that
like to be if you do enjoy subscribe for
new I covered the informational site a
foreigner that being the ballots changes
to hear updates the patch notes and the
leaks
if won't be kept up to date with
everything happenings in the world
foreigner I never miss out on an update
if we stay subscribe to channel and with
that hopefully we'll get some viewer for
info next week that I can share with you
all that be sick for that peace out guys
have a great week
you